welcome to the man of recaps this is the
walking dead season 11 episode 2. and
remember the best way to watch these new
episodes is on amc plus click the link
in the description to sign up now and
join in for the epic final season last
episode ended when negan did not help
maggie up and she fell off the train
into the zombie horde turns out though
that's really not as big a deal as they
made it seem it's not that far a fall
and there's fewer zombies than we
thought and though she does get swarmed
maggie's able to escape by crawling
under the dumpster i mean train the rest
of the group comes down from the top and
makes it inside the train they're like
hey where's maggie and negan's like i
don't know pretty soon though maggie
shows up and as you might imagine is
even madder than usual at negan she
considered shooting him in the face
immediately but negan talks his way out
of it he's like hey i didn't try to kill
you i just didn't help you there's a big
difference plus maggie be honest you
would have done the same to me and just
then they're distracted by a new
situation one of the guys that got
separated is coming in from the other
train car the door is jammed they'd have
to pry it open but there's a whole bunch
of zombies coming up behind him maggie's
like hey if we open that door they're
all getting in we gotta let him die so
he pulls out his knife and stabs himself
so he's dead by the time the zombies
brutally rip him apart maggie what
happened to you to make you so cold well
she tells a long story i won't go into
details because it's one of the darkest
most atrocious stories i've ever heard
but long story short one day she came
across some guys that were holding some
girls captive and it was bad now let's
check in with the commonwealth crew they
decided not to escape because yumiko
found out her brother's probably inside
now we found out last episode that
yumiko was a lawyer and a pretty high
powered one because she went to harvard
and oxford so she decides it's time to
be assertive she marches right up to a
stormtrooper like hey i demand to speak
to the manager she talks to these
interviews again and basically tells
them off like hey this whole
intimidation thing's not gonna work on
me like i'm the master of intimidation
i'm intimidating you meanwhile princess
and eugene are waiting outside princess
is like hey can i go to the bathroom and
they're like yeah sure go ahead but she
never comes back and when eugene goes to
check on her they don't tell him
anything king ezekiel also disappeared
so now eugene is all alone and he's
pretty sure that his friends are all
killed so when they bring him in for
interrogation he is a mess and now he's
talking directly to the orange power
ranger and this guy is very intimidating
he's like eugene i know you've been
lying to me tell me the truth where is
your big settlement and what were you
doing in the train station eugene seems
to be totally broken he's like all right
i'll tell you everything but actually he
does not give up alexandria he sticks to
the story they're the entire crew he is
maybe too honest though about how he met
stephanie over the radio and how he was
really hoping that things could work out
between him because he's a virgin so
yeah nothing devious here he's just a
horny guy on a booty call apparently
that answer was good enough cause he's
reunited with his friends in a much more
welcoming train car mr orange reads them
the official welcome by commonwealth
charter section 11a or whatever like you
pass processing welcome and the first
person that comes to greet them is
stephanie yeah she's real and appears to
have genuinely been interested in eugene
now back in the subway train the group
is stuck for now all these doors are
rusted shut before they can get their
exit door open the zombies are breaking
through the other one so it's zombie
fighting time apparently they're low on
ammo but father gabriel decides to waste
all the rest of it right away then they
switch to arrows yeah our group's got a
good system going funneling them through
this tight hallway and when they run out
of arrows it's melee time oh man there's
so many zombies though and when some
walkers are coming from the other side
maggie tells negan to go deal with them
and she gives him her gun yeah she
accepts they have this uneasy truce
where she can't fully trust him but
working together is their best chance of
survival meanwhile daryl followed dog
another way he comes across an old camp
and spends a lot of time just looking at
what these people's lives were about
long story short daryl makes it to the
train now and over the course of the
episode we've seen him fight with his
crossbow and with his double knives and
with his morning star but now daryl
decides to bust out a pistol and it's
been a very long time since we've seen
daryl use a gun in fact have we ever but
turns out he's a pro it's this one take
awesome shot oh walking through the
train john wick's style blah blah he
also has a grenade bam smashes it in the
zombie's mouth and kicks him out there
slams the door shut bloom exploded them
all daryl badass leveled a hundred and
so our gang finally makes it out of the
subway tunnels maggie actually has a
supply cache nearby with some food and
weapons she's like let's stop by there
it's gonna be cool but on the way they
find posts along the side of the road
with people hanging upside down from
them in fact they're lining the whole
road all the way down it's like maybe we
shouldn't go this way but oh it's too
late daryl's attacking him yes it's the
reapers looking badass coming on down oh
that's intimidating and that's where the
episode comes to an end another great
episode you want to be watching these
and you know the best way to do it is on
amc plus stream each new episode ad free
from any device and on amc plus only the
episodes are available one week early
the sunday before right now there's a
special deal the annual plan is only
4.99 a month click the link in the
description to start your free trial of
amc plus now and join in for this epic
final season the beginning of the end of
the walking dead
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you loved
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member